[Music]
winds at the surface in excess of 140
miles an hour it's equivalent to an ef3
tornado fifteen thousand feet above the
surface its superheated gases and
flaming gases getting lifted into this
violently rotating column of air the Sun
is almost entirely blotted out by the
smoke it's you know this hellscape of
midnight at noon and raining fire I
can't last you all here okay if you can
get out safely get out okay
oh yeah did I give you my life phone
number this is a fire tornado my name is
Neil Darrell I'm an assistant professor
at the University of Nevada Reno and I'm
an atmospheric scientist and we're here
to talk about fire weather and in
particular fired tornadoes
when we're talking about winds of 140
miles an hour I people don't really
understand just how strong that is we're
talking about lofting cars off of the
ground we're talking about crumpling
large steel structures potentially
ripping roofs off houses and then you
add that with flaming gases and intense
combustion and we're talking about
really you know one of it one of the
most extreme sort of phenomenon that you
can you can witness fire was whipped up
into a a whirlwind of activity you know
uprooting trees moving vehicles moving
parts of roadways so let's talk about
how fire tornadoes form true fire
tornadoes have only been documented now
twice once in red in California during
the car fire and once in Canberra
Australia during 2003 the unique aspect
the car fire was the the presence of
these kind of ambient shear winds in the
environment and that that was really
setting the stage for the development of
this tornado the updraft is simply a
rising current of air in this case
generated by the heat of the fire we
know that hot air rises and so we're
putting a huge amount of heat into the
atmosphere right above the fire and all
of that air is going to accelerate
upward and so that's the primary updraft
driven by the fire when air flows up
it also necessitates air to flow in all
of the air that's going up has to be
replaced from somewhere and so it's
going to draw air in from the sides and
this is what we might call an inflow jet
or a fire induced wind which is a
horizontal wind that is essentially
converging from all directions into the
location of the updraft the other thing
that we're seeing in the case of the the
car fire is the presence of wind shear
in the environment which is air flowing
in different directions
adjacent to the other air stream and you
can picture this like a highway median
with traffic going in one direction
separated from traffic going in the
other direction over just a short
distance this is actually if you picture
a pinwheel or something in this flow
actually gives you rotation and
environment and so that's our kind of
source of initial rotation
but there's something kind of
interesting that's happening here that
is what we call a vicious cycle or
positive feedback normally if you don't
have rotation in this big flaming column
of hot gases rising off of the fire it
will readily mix with its environment so
you'll get these big eddies that form on
the side of the of the updraft that pull
in colder air from the surroundings they
help cool off the air in there and
dilute that air once you get rotation
you are no longer able to mix air into
this column as effectively so starts
acting a little bit more like a chimney
and the flaming can persist through a
much greater depth in the atmosphere and
so it's retaining its heat much better
than it would be otherwise and that's
allowing it to stay stronger the updraft
is stronger the inflow winds are
stronger and then the combustion is
stronger at the surface so really a
vicious cycle here
[Music]
people often confuse what we would
consider to be a fire tornado with fire
whirl
maybe not all fire scientists or
meteorologists exactly agree on what
distinguishes between fire whirls and
fire tornadoes fire tornadoes and fire
whirls both start with strong updrafts
from the fire and strong inflows related
to the fire itself but fire tornadoes
get even bigger because the fire is
actually initiating its own weather
system helping to concentrate the
rotation in the lower atmosphere
[Music]
fire tornadoes actually develop a link
to what's called an overlying pyro
cumulonimbus cloud which is a fancy word
for fire generated thunderstorm and so
the column of hot air rising from the
wildfire can actually then trigger its
own weather system its own thunderstorm
there's actually a fair bit of water
vapor inside of this big smoke plume
coming off of the fire in as the plume
gets higher and higher in the atmosphere
it eventually reaches a point that it's
actually cold enough that it can no
longer hold the initial amount of water
that it had it and it forces that water
to go from the invisible phase into a
liquid cloud droplet and we see this as
a bright white cloud that develops in
the plume every time some of that water
has to be forced into a cloud droplet it
dumps some heat back into the atmosphere
the fancy term that we have for this is
latent heat or latent heat release
latent heat releases when water changes
phase from water vapor invisible water
vapor into visible white cloud droplets
and it dumps some heat out during that
process and when you have millions of
droplets doing that that amount of heat
is tremendous and so this is what fuels
an ordinary thunderstorm the heat
release inside of the cloud and so when
a fire does this it's kind of doubling
the effect of the fire because we have
the initial heat from the fire is
driving this big column of air going up
it gets deep enough and then it starts
adding heat back into the column and it
will rise even even further into the
atmosphere and once that happens the
cloud really has a mind of its own and
will really rapidly vertically develop
long distance spotting is really scary
in that you're throwing embers in
advance of the fire which can actually
go quite some distance in front of the
fire you know a mile in front of the
fire and these are going to start new
fires and so we can see this in paradise
for example where we have embers raining
down from the sky and starting all sorts
of new fires
[Music]
sometimes you'll get this pockety
distribution of things that did burn and
things that don't burn one house may
burn because the geometry of its
roofline lets these embers build up or
there is a fuel bed next to the house
that is very receptive to these whereas
a more irrigated surface even though
those embers may be falling on it may
not ignite and sometimes we see these
green spaces and communities you know
essentially be untouched by the fire
even though embers may be falling there
and then just extreme flame lengths and
flames
moving horizontally through through the
landscape I has really devastating
impacts in the case of fires like the
campfire or other strong wind driven
fires like the tubs fire the devastated
parts of Santa Rosa we have very strong
ambient winds moving through the
environment as well and they just are
pushing the flames and pushing the
embers in a sheet across the landscape
the house is add to the fuel
significantly once we move into town the
fire is going to behave differently
because the fuels are different you get
a change in fire behavior and a change
in the strength of your updrafts the
depth of this big column of air as you
move into the into the settled area
those houses are very rich fuel sources
for a fire
you can't you know rely on just you know
what what we've seen in the past and in
some of these environments right now
being cognizant of the factors that
could go into forming a truly
devastating fire tornado and fire
generated thunderstorms is is an
important challenge for forecasters and
for fire managers to look out for these
events in the future and ultimately try
to get people out of harm's way and an
expedient fashion we can clearly see
that fires have gotten bigger you know
we have a lengthening fire season
globally but also here in California the
longer fire season the bigger fires that
we're having essentially give us more
opportunity to experience the range of
extreme fire behavior that are possible
firefighters are the ones on the front
line of this and they're often relying
on their experiences or the crew bosses
experience with fire how fire has
behaved in that landscape in the past
what sort of behaviors you can expect
from the fire but as we see these
outlier events rules of thumb or past
personal experience they're not going to
capture the full range of potential
extreme fire behavior
[Music]
you